any uk mission  that is that follows the us airstrikes  is not going to contribute positively  to what's happening with allen or the  release efforts behind the scenes  and i implore the uk government to  think very carefully before they abandon  these western hostages and they abandon  these people  that are their citizens  um we hope and pray that alan is safe  wherever he is  with u.s airstrikes already  happening it's extremely difficult for  us to  comprehend what may be happening on the  ground  and if they are targeting the places  that  these captors are holding him then it  may well be  that  that the us or the uk government could  be responsible for anything that happens  to alan henning